yeah Jets running back Libyan bell
joining us on the program good morning
how are you and where are you right now
lab young hello hey in here we go
okay where are you right now I'm on my
way to Percy limo later he was when I'm
in the car
oh hi did you did you pull over to the
side of the road for this I mean I did
but secondly we drive we attract so it's
like I don't want you to get in trouble
here right oh okay okay that's good did
you watch the game last night what do
you watch for when you watch those games
I mean really entertainment you know for
real but like I watched my favorite
players I guess it was like one of my
favorite players to watch you know it's
not like it's really watching and you
see a large played a game who do you
think could you see Russell Wilson as a
running back
no because I see you in the quarterback
okay but like Lamar Jackson if let's say
you were gonna have him as a running
back for a season
could he be a running back in the NFL
running for today that makes sense you
know
it's like you know he just on the edge
is he like you just scrambled you know
cuz it's wrong and things like that but
I don't know if like here but you know
really take just running the ball okay
well the punishment that you get it you
know quarterback runs sometimes when he
wants to run as opposed to when the
defense's know you're going to run and
then you've thrown one pass in your
career I think
you remember it I'm sorry did you you
thrown one pass in your career yeah yeah
you remember you remember then I do yeah
and what happened so your quarterback
rating is not very good hey how did you
develop your style of running which
which you know there's patience and then
you know there's quickness were you
taught that running style you know I'm
still of course playing football for how
many years I've been playing are things
that kind of actually just happened for
me we're talking to Le'Veon Bell the
Jets running back how important was that
when I know any wins important but to
beat the Giants that was huge you know I
mean obviously everybody knew it was for
you know bragging rights in New York and
uh you know beating the Giants so
obviously we both play at MetLife
Stadium for all games dentists or you
know both both sides and teams so it has
to be in our stadium maybe as much as it
was you know it was a very fun the
interseting game and we made sure that
we were to get that get that way than we
did I explain what you're doing today
you're going to be in an armored truck
driving around New York City yeah it's a
new cash back program that Wars buying
your favourite statue Thanks all right
so what do you you're spending the day
in the armored truck I mean not the
entire day we'll have fun with that and
if people see the armored truck what are
they supposed to do
I mean I'm surprising New York I'm
surprising New York surprising New York
in the chest so I mean I don't know what
they're supposed to do I mean I don't
know what about the burn - I think if
I've seen that fire I see no harm but
turned out by trying to work yeah well
have fun today and thanks for taking
some time with us levy on we appreciate
it
all right let's levy unbound the Jets
running back for more Dan Patrick show
tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV streamed for free on BR Live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]